i feel like we've all been put on this
earth for a reason okay and i think that
there is just different skills or
different things different tools we're
not all supposed to be the same right
some of us will be the creators some of
us will be
the directors and the leaders some
people will be the innovators but it's
having the spaciousness to really tap
into that which a lot of us don't
because we have to pay the bills and we
have to do this and that but it's like
how might i leave my mark hey friends
and welcome back to deep dive the
ongoing podcast where i have
conversations with authors creators
entrepreneurs and other inspiring people
about how they got to where they are and
the strategies and tools that we can use
to help us live our collective best
lives i've just finished having a
discussion with samantha clark the
author of this sick book love it or
leave it how to be happy at work
samantha is uh happiness researchers
consult like happiness consultant is
probably a fair way of saying it she's a
lecturer at the school of life which
you've no doubt come across on youtube
and other formats and she's built a
super interesting portfolio career
starting out as like a marketing person
and then moving into shoes into design
into fashion and now is somehow ending
up in this route where she advises huge
companies and also individuals and
coaches people on how to find happiness
and work and i think you're really gonna
enjoy this conversation we touch on a
bunch of stuff like we do talk a lot
about this idea of happiness we talk
about the six pillars of what it means
to be happy in your career we talk about
the concepts in a love it or leave it
which is basically her kind of
coaching model for helping people
navigate career changes in life and
really i took so much away from this it
almost felt like a bit of a personal
coaching slash therapy session um
discovered a few new interesting tools
like um kind of human design and stuff
that i'm gonna explore a bit more but
really samantha really challenged me to
think harder about
you know what
what i want from my own life and my own
career and i'm hoping that by listening
to this conversation you'll be able to
sort of put yourself in my shoes like
the way that i was kind of asking the
questions and sort of essentially being
coached through the process and what i'm
hoping the conversation will do for you
is spark some thought that you wouldn't
have had before listening to this
something that makes you think oh
interesting and that makes you think of
your career and maybe nudges your life
trajectory in a slightly different
direction than it might have been before
um i'm still reeling from the effects of
this conversation and thinking oh my god
i need to spend the next like two hours
just really thinking and sitting and
thinking about like the stuff that we
were talking about um which is what i'm
going to do with my little journal my
little my little pen um but anyway i
hope you enjoyed this conversation
between me and samantha clark
especially now i think we're in such
fluid times that it's okay to be
i think we have to make peace with being
many things
but also reworking what the word doctor
could mean i mean you could be the
doctor of stories in the way that you
are
you know creating lots of different
experiences and giving people a
prescription of somewhat of things that
they can do through your videos oh yeah
it's good thinking about it i feel like
there's so many word plays that you can
do with titles that no longer fit us in
one capacity yep but could be evolved
into something else was that something
that you were worried about as you were
kind of changing careers like what is
what is my label
i think my parents were probably worried
oh okay yeah they were like
how do we sell you in you know like when
you go to family events
i
i think maybe there was a period of time
where i didn't feel like i fit in
because all my friends had you know like
they were following a certain route and
here i was doing a bit of style coaching
on wednesday and then i'd be you know
speaking and consulting with a client in
korea the next day and they're like what
is it that you do so i feel like
everyone else also has the issue around
it like i don't know where to position
you or what box to put you in and then
it becomes a little bit uneasy for them
but i think after a while i just stood
firm with the fact that i love to do
lots of things and i always will love to
do lots of things
and that's okay and if it's okay with me
then that's that's what matters yeah
what's the point of work
like
any any thoughts on that like
what's the deal with work like why why
why why why well i mean
i think it's that question of was funny
i was having this conversation with a
couple of friends recently and one has
just closed her business down and she
you know said i
i just realized that i was working
really hard to kind of fuel an engine i
didn't believe in anymore or i felt
differently about
and it also wasn't giving me the revenue
that i wanted
and then you know another friend is very
purpose driven so for her work is
knowing that she's making a ripple
effect on other people
and so i think it is then us defining
how do we want work to shape us like how
do we how do we see ourselves growing
and how can work be
fueled for that fire and not take us
away from it so i definitely know that i
am here in this world to be a supporter
to to
help to create transformations i like to
connect the dots for people
and
at the moment work doesn't feel like
work it feels like play and the more
that i look for the play and it feel
less like this is the grind that i need
to do to pay the bills
which you know is probably a bit of a
privilege because there's a lot of
people who still need to be in that
functional way of thinking about work
but
maybe
to give us that to help us take a step
back from it it's just thinking like
what's the effect that you want to have
on your time your time here
like what do you want to do yeah like in
your sharing people's stories you're
helping your community
change lives or do things differently so
that's not a bad kind of work to be
honest but is it just the fact of
getting up to do something does it feel
repetitive for you or do you just feel
like actually i've tapped out of
like what's the meaning of all of this
yeah like the way i'm i'm kind of
thinking about it is like work on one
level is clearly instrumental in
letting us make enough money to survive
but then if that was out of the equation
right exactly
but then i think then it's about
exploring yourself and maybe i do have
quite i feel like we've all been put on
this earth for a reason okay and i think
that there is just different skills or
different things different tools we're
not all supposed to be the same right
some of us will be the creators some of
us will be
the directors and the leaders some
people will be the innovators but it's
having the spaciousness to really tap
into that which a lot of us don't
because we have to pay the bills and we
have to do this and that but it's like
what would i how might i leave my mark
what is going to be my legacy i think we
have to all think about that whether or
not you are the caretaker in a school or
ceo of big company what about the whole
notion apparently it was a thing more
back in the day where it's like oh you
know it's just a job i survived the nine
to five so that i can enjoy the five to
nine and work basically just being this
thing that you know i speak to my mum
about this sometimes and it's when when
we're talking about this this thing that
i do have like youtube videos and
podcasts and like working on a book and
like the portfolio-y type stuff one
thing that she'll sometimes say is that
you know the the fun and games has to
stop sometimes oh yeah you've got to
become an adult sometimes yeah
but you know we're looking at
cross-cultural and generational
differences i remember i'd be
at home and i was living at home at that
point and you know my dad would be like
you haven't done any work all day and
i've been on my laptop like you know
working doing reports creating
presentations but in his mind you went
somewhere you did a solid day's job and
then you came back and you had those
stories to retell and here i was just
like tapping away at the dining table on
my laptop and i think there's also for
them and maybe speaking of my parents it
wasn't easy
the workplace
and i think and you know i think some
things have changed and some things
haven't but you know there was certain
pride in like doing good work and
delivering great value and you know my
mom worked in nursing for a period of
time so that was like you know every day
she could see how she was making a
difference
so i think there's different notions and
values we attribute to work and i think
generationally we have to also make
peace with the fact that they'll never
see
the work that you do
in the same way and that's okay yeah i
guess for us compared to our parents
generation work is more of that like
that driver of i want to feel as if my
work is meaningful right they weren't
interested in
creative fulfillment and all of this
kind of you know i've got to pay the
bills right they were building and they
were trying to provide for you know my
generation and lay good foundations
things that they never had and it was
the you went you did this and you you
know you came back and although i think
that was evolving for my mom because she
then you know started her masters and
went into different routes in her career
and then also wanted to start her own
entrepreneurial thing so i think you
know after a while she was then thinking
okay actually
i love this job but there's other things
that i'm being called to do yep which
she's now experimenting with in her 70s
so it's like okay yeah but maybe that i
believe i'll take the credit for it but
i do think that i have actually inspired
her to think about how all these many
things that she probably wanted to do or
start businesses were all there it's
just like she just needed to see it
shine a light on it and just be brave to
try it we had a team retreat a few weeks
ago in wales it's like this nice
location i was i was having a bunch of
sort of casual conversations with people
in our team
basically asking you know like if you
didn't have to work what would you be
doing with your time and like one of our
team members mentioned that you know
she's like singing she's like sitting
over there actually uh and just has
incredible singing voice like started
making videos on like youtube and
instagram and a little bit of streaming
around singing and her whole thing was
that like yeah i'd i'd really want to
explore the singing thing so my next
question is like oh what's stopping you
and then there's some kind of barrier of
like oh but like um i feel like i don't
have the time with a day job i was like
well we could easily
put you down to three days a week
part-time like what would be stopping
you then and it was almost like there
was this emotional block or some sort of
hurdle that's like sort of that that
step beyond the threshold of like i'm
actually going to follow that dream and
i imagine this is something you hear a
lot like
how how should people navigate that
kind of
potential leap yeah we all have
different blocks for lots of different
reasons right so for whatever notion
there is a talk about this in
psychotherapy that we all have a live
script
and
it is generally a script that was
embedded in you from about seven or so
and then you are then perpetually living
it or trying to run away from it
and a lot of our actions sometimes
depending on our personality traits our
historical upbringing these can deter
you from taking decisions and you almost
self-sabotage without knowing it so
things will bubble up like i don't think
i'll be good enough or if i have that
space how would i use it and so then you
know we fall into procrastination zone
or maybe we feel like we need to be
perfect before we take any kind of leap
so we spend a lot of time doing the prep
and the planning and no no action and so
it's really about dissecting what is
getting in the way of me taking that
leap is it that i personally i'm lacking
the confidence am i lacking the
connections is there a fear of feeling
not good enough to do it and you know
especially now people are like oh my god
there's thousands of people doing this
that and the other on instagram how do i
make a dent in it but if you don't try
and start
you'll never know but the key things
that i see with people is there is
definitely some of psychological
barrier that there's the inner critic
that's really loud about what can and
can't be done and generally we use time
or money those are the biggest excuses
or sometimes whether or not we have the
support system is another one yep and
it's taking the notion to kind of unpack
all of that and just think actually is
this also something i really do want to
do
because we can talk about a lot of
things
but fundamentally if you were doing that
day in day out with does this hobby need
to turn into something that you monetize
hmm
that's a good point yeah because often
monetizing a hobby and making it into a
job takes a lot of the joy out of it
right and so sometimes there's always
that question of okay maybe i'm really
good at singing and it just needs to
stay there yeah so i guess it's about
really exploring the hidden assumptions
behind
the things like when you when you go and
do something or when you try to pivot in
a new direction what's the automatic
voice that comes up is it that i don't
have enough money i don't know what i'm
doing i don't have any connections i'm
not going to be good enough okay so take
one of them and then start to whittle it
down well
who says i'm not good enough like where
is there the critique or the the proof
that states what i can and can't do if i
realize actually maybe you know i can't
reach this particular range and i really
want to move into opera maybe i need
some training am i prepared to pay for
that am i prepared to go in that journey
and you know through doing that yourself
or with a partner friend whatever start
to realize like what are these
self-imposed barriers
and how do you break them down to move
forwards yeah that's good i think
the sorts of conversations i end up
having with the coaches that we work
with where often you know my mom or
someone else will ask me like why are
you paying so much money for this coach
they're just asking the right questions
at the right time and it's like it's
like in a way just having an hour to sit
down and really
break down the assumptions that are
holding me back
from doing a thing that i want to do
it's just like incredibly valuable yeah
and that could easily be done with a
friend who just knows how to ask the
right questions as well but i guess we
often don't make time for it when it
comes to friends we don't make time for
it but also it's you know it's hard
sometimes when you know your friends
kind of know you they also know you in
one particular way yeah perhaps also
they don't they're fearful themselves of
taking leaps and so we can only advise
or coach somebody as far as we're
willing to go yeah
and so it is just thinking okay if i
speak to somebody outside of my realm
and they can view my work through a
different lens
um and that's what i love i love just
asking my clients really provocative
questions
to help to push them out of that because
that's what happens most of us just go
round and round in spirals and get
really stuck and we either get really
frustrated there yeah and you know we
absorb that as stress and it turns into
something else or we do something about
it yeah one of the questions that one of
my coaches corey often asks is like what
are the assumptions that you're making
behind that statement you'll often say
something and he gets he's from texas
he'll put on his like texan voice and be
like oh interesting
what are the assumptions there what sort
of questions do you like to ask
so sometimes i get them to interrogate
they're in the critic and so to have a
conversation with it so they either
becomes a muse or somebody who is like
dead against you doing this thing yeah
and so i was facilitate that
conversation i'm always curious to know
you know to get them to look at the
polarities of like okay this thing
you say is not really good but what
happens if it's a real mega success
and i think oftentimes what we don't
talk about enough is that fear of
success
fear of success how might that change me
if i do really well in this how might i
move out of
the comfort zone or the realm that i'm
in now how might people perceive me
differently if i move into a different
realm and sometimes that ends up keeping
us just paddling under
a certain level because we're fearful to
push ourselves too much
so that definitely gets a rise i think
i'm always curious to know like where
did where did you first hear that
thought oh nice because that is us
really picturing where have i
internalized this narrative
or where did i hear that or what was i
seeing
that then cultivated this mindset of i
can't do that or that's beyond my reach
or that's not possible for me where did
you first hear that alrighty just a
quick interlude before we continue with
the episode now if you would like to
train your mind for peace and purpose
every day you might like to check out
the book think like a monk by j shetty i
read this i think the first day that it
came out i think it was about two years
ago and turned it into a book club video
on my channel uh that'll be linked down
below if you want to check out the book
summary but actually to be honest a far
better way of getting a summary of the
book is by using short form who are very
kindly sponsoring this episode if you
haven't heard by now short form is the
world's best service that summarizes
books uh but it's way more than just a
summary of the book so firstly they have
one pages that summarize the ideas of
the book in a single page secondly they
have chapter by chapter summaries like
in detail that break down the main ideas
of each chapter they also kind of build
on those ideas and so they'll include
some interactive exercises in between
some of the sections so you can engage
with the book a little bit more and if
the author says something particularly
controversial or something that another
author has disagreed with then they'll
include a short form note that kind of
builds on the ideas and that kind of
says that hey hang on there's an
alternative viewpoint there's a bit more
nuance here than there is in the book
it's not a replacement for reading the
book itself but for example if you find
yourself short on time like i do a lot
then what i tend to do is that if i get
a book recommendation and i'm not 100
sold and whether i want to read it i
will read the short form summary of it
first and if i like the summary or if i
don't like the summary or if i think
that i want to read the book after
reading the summary then i'll read the
book and then i'll highlight it on
kindle and do all the usual stuff short
form is also really good for revisiting
ideas from books that you've already
read i'm using it a ton these days
firstly for any time i need to make a
book summary video for my youtube
channel i will use short form because
it's just a way easier way and it's
actually very well structured and often
they structure the book in a slightly
different way than the author does so
it's a way of exploring the same topic
from two different angles first angle
being the one in the book itself and the
second angle being sort of the way that
short form condenses everything down
it's also really helpful for my own book
research because there's i you know
there's dozens and dozens and dozens of
books that i want to mine for content
for the stuff that i write whether it's
my books or blog posts or newsletters or
youtube videos but instead of me having
to read all these books i can just get
the main ideas from short form and if i
then do want to explore something a
little bit more at that point i can get
the book and explore just that specific
point in a little bit more detail if any
of that sums up your street and you
would like to get access to the world's
best book summaries then head over to
short form dot com forward slash deep
dive and that url will give you 20 off
the annual premium subscription so thank
you very much short form for sponsoring
this episode i'd love to talk a little
bit about sort of the methodology of the
book so the title love it or leave it
how to be happy at work i mean i'm in
the process of working on a book right
now and we're struggling to come up with
a title i just saw this title i was like
oh that's a really good title because it
takes that
like it's kind of obvious what the book
is about but it's also like like oh
somewhat like counterintuitive advice
like love it or like
you hear people say that but when it
comes to work i imagine it it would be
very easy for people to sort of think
that that's a particularly controversial
title that oh you either love your job
or you leave it like
what about my bills what about abcde
what about career progression what about
all these other things you're not taking
into account yeah so how do you like
what what's the process if someone's
listening to this and maybe they've
maybe got a job or they're a student on
a track to a job that they may not fully
enjoy how do we
how do we advise them love it or leave
it yeah yeah so i was actually teaching
this workshop for a while at the
guardian right and i was writing another
book which had a very different title
and it just wasn't sticking and my agent
was going on matt leave and she
connected me to another agent she's like
have a word with him if not we'll just
pause it and come back to it and he was
like yeah this this title is [ __ ]
and i was like oh
it was something i can't remember i
think it was like happiness gym or
something
yeah he was just like nice [ __ ] so i
was like what do you mean i spent ages
on this and he was like no it's not you
because it just doesn't speak to you i
feel like you're a little bit like
provocative controversial i feel like we
need something that's going to be a bit
divisive and just get people thinking
and he's like tell me what else you're
doing and i told him about his workshop
he's like that's your book you guys can
just see people in the airport going
love it or leave it or you know on some
like conundrum before the holiday like
oh okay that's a great read
and i guess for me i was always
when i was working one-to-one with
people there was always this tug of war
like i just don't want to do that
revolutionary step of just quitting and
leaving
and i don't think we have to i don't
think it has to be this so black and
white all or nothing i think there is a
real
pro to looking at both sides of the coin
and loving it is getting people to
explore how do i
learn more about myself and my
self-awareness to see how i'm
interacting with the space the people
and thinking about the context of work
and what could i do to make some tweaks
there to see how that ripples out and
changes
and
you know i want people to really
question how do you work effectively who
do you work with what type of work do
you enjoy where are you flatlining
throughout the day
and how can you start to just
tease out what is actually good about
what you're doing you know we can
complain a lot but actually getting us
to think grateful or you know
hone in on what actually works and how
can i start to tease out more of that
yep
and then the love it's the leave it side
was okay so if you have tried that and
actually your job might be very toxic it
might be um that you have seen some
other opportunities that you love to
leap into yeah like this is how you
leave it and these are the precautions
that you take when you're thinking about
leaving it so you know thinking about
money thinking about your connections
thinking about your well-being as you go
through transitions is it a job or is it
creating a portfolio career
and i love chapter 10 in the book
because it is basically giving you that
run-through of how to create a portfolio
career because i think a lot of people
maybe are realizing i don't fit into
this box and that's possibly why i want
to leave yeah so
i guess for those who are in roles at
the moment you know a lot of the
exercises in the first one are broken
down into people job role and kind of
sector and i guess i've done a lot more
work on my like i guess methodology
around what i call the six happiness
pillars for individuals to think about
when it comes to work so there is body
mind body soul so like really thinking
about how
your
role or work is affecting you in that
area
um money magic so really noticing like
what are the things that i value is it
recognition money how am i managing my
money and you know if i was to go full
time am i okay with risk and then we get
people in place so what are the types of
people in the environments that really
support me and that i feel i can
flourish in systems and flow like the
types of tasks when we break it down and
get very granular purpose umbrella yeah
so you know who who do i want to become
and how is this work shaping me and then
the last one is around your portfolio
pie so like what is the kinds of things
that you want to make you want your work
to be made up of and so i think when i
help people the people that i support
one to one or in groups you know really
breaking down like what is going right
in the job across some of those areas
what actually is more important to you
and that you're not getting and then how
might that fuel a move or a you know
sideways step in your career or
different what sort of patterns come up
when when you have these kind of
conversations the big ones definitely
purpose like i don't feel this job is is
guiding me towards purpose or feels like
i'm making a bigger den in what
you know i want to am i just a cog in
the wheel
i think there is definitely something
around
the mind-body soul connection like how
is this job affecting my psyche my
well-being like i don't feel confident
when i leave this company every day or
you know as i start my working day this
trepidation and fear and anxiety i don't
i don't want to live like that anymore
those are the top two
that i think are
really and then it's just a case of i
would say third would probably be
how do i fuse all the different things
that i'm good at yeah cause i guess like
i've i've done a bunch of digging into
sort of management literature and around
the idea that when people are using
their strengths at work every day that
just like profoundly makes everything
just feel way more fun and better and
nice yeah but it's strengths in the way
that i think strengths can sometimes be
misconstrued with
people thinking just because i am great
at organizing things doesn't mean that i
constantly want to do that so i think
there's a fine balance between strengths
that you're competent in in strengths
that actually energize you okay and
finding that sweet spot in the middle
between the things that you love doing
that you actually get joy out of versus
what people tell you you're good at
therefore you get pushed into a cycle of
doing that
a bunch of questions so on the mind body
soul front what sort of questions should
you be looking uh asking yourself kind
of before the day after the work day to
sort of assess your level of mind body
soul and leanness in work yeah you know
what am i excited to tackle today
when i think about work how do i feel
throughout my body throughout the
working day so where are you noticing
stress or tension when you think about
your intentions like how am i
something that i support my clients to
do is think intentionally how am i
stepping into my day like what are the
kinds of attitudes behaviors that i'd
like to continue to be consistent with
and where do i get knocked off
or where do i feel that my triggers or
my insecurities flare up and make me
move in a different direction also like
what's the level of stress throughout
your working day is this stuff that is
it the stress that kelly mcgonnell talks
about that is there to challenge you and
push you further or is it actually
grinding you down and making you more
anxious
and then as you wind down for the day
you know really thinking about what
worked well throughout the day what
would i like to you know keep doing more
of yeah am i making time to be present
to pause to eat
to fuel my body you know because
sometimes we just run on adrenaline and
we're not built for that yeah yeah
that's the thing that happens with
doctors a lot where it's like you're in
the middle of a shift and it's very easy
to just forget lunch but like the good
seniors are the ones that are like no
like
take a lunch break right now and you
need it our brain needs the fuel to
perform right and yet we think that even
our phones need charging so we have to
really be mindful about the time that we
take to
to just monitor what's going on with our
body and how we're reacting to different
environments and whether or not we're
giving it the nourishment it needs to
take us to the next level yeah on the
purpose front so i i guess for something
like again like being a nurse being a
doctor the purpose behind it is i feel
often quite clear it's like i'm helping
this person in front of me
but a lot of jobs are more removed from
what feels like direct impact like i've
got a bunch of friends in management
consulting who are like ugh
yeah i'm kind of working for this big
corporation and making powerpoint slides
for them and it's like they really
struggle with this question of purpose
because like how the hell do you connect
that to a wider purpose have you kind of
found any any patterns with that sort of
thing yeah it's funny because i think
that was my original issue when i was in
um advertising i was wondering
i couldn't see the direct link between
you know my work and then some digital
campaign on some sugary cereal like how
is that really affecting the kid i
wanted i think i was really craving to
see the direct impact and to work more
closely with one-to-one people i think
there's something about noticing the
company that you work for and whether or
not you can see
what you're creating is being you know
supporting the wider goal or the wider
community
and then also asking yourself the
question i had this with a client
recently i was like does your work need
to be that purpose for you like can you
find it outside of work is that
something actually if this work actually
just really fuels the life that you set
up for yourself and what you need to do
but actually you're really interested in
you know coaching young startups around
ip law like could that be not be
something that you do on the weekends in
the evening that you have you know your
mentoring so i think sometimes we have
to be mindful to try to force everything
into this job
and much like your partner they can't be
everything yeah you will have friends
who will provide different things you'll
have you know and maybe the core
qualities that you look for in your
partner is what sustains you and
everything else holds you into place and
so in a way provided that work has the
core qualities that you're looking for
it doesn't necessarily need to take all
of the boxes they might not need to for
some people it might be actually it's a
non-negotiable and then they're in the
wrong business so then the management
consultancy might not be for them and
they need to make peace with i need to
do a clean sweep and move elsewhere or
for somebody else it might be like
actually you know i'm making these power
points i'm interested in what i'm doing
but fundamentally i love you know
painting schools or build it or like
thinking about how i can work with old
people and
you know think about that and maybe
that's something that i do consistently
out or i downsize and do three days
a week and two days i'm volunteering at
an all people's home like
there are ways that around that we can
do that it's just also what we're
willing to let go of because we cannot
have both yeah and i guess it's about
figuring out sort of that self-awareness
to figure out for yourself what is the
thing that actually matters yeah and
what is the thing that you can sort of
maybe in an ideal world you would you
would take all these boxes and work but
if you if you had to which of them would
you want to what kind of the top and
also like maybe you ask you do a little
ask a friend survey there's one in the
book that you can you know what is it
that i'm really good at that you come to
me for when you think about i need help
with x oh my god ali is a right person
for that you know sometimes we aren't
aware of our brilliance
things that we take for granted skills
that we just you know just haphazardly
throw away but actually to someone else
that's a really pivotal thing that you
provide for them where does money come
into this in the sense that anyone you
ask will say will will feel like they
probably don't have enough money and
you know there's that whole thing around
you know if you ask people how much
money they need to be happy they always
say two to three times as much as they
currently have
and you know i've spoken to
entrepreneurs who have got like 10
million in the bank who are like yeah
you know i think i'll be fine once i've
got 25 million when it comes to
navigating a career i guess again
thinking back to conversations i've had
with a bunch of my friends
it's like oh you know i'm currently
working at mckinsey and it's like oh you
know the the next bonus is just around
the corner it's just like oh it's a
little carrying stick isn't it it feels
like oh like once i get that next bonus
at that point oh well then the next
one's just six months around the corner
so i might as well stick it out and in a
way there is almost this sort of
capitalist drive to accumulate more and
more
and i guess we can always you know and
this is the thing that i really took
away from the four-hour work week around
we always think that like the life that
we want requires more money than we
currently have
well like how do you how do you go about
navigating the money thing because i
imagine that's something that comes up a
lot with people yeah i i don't know i
feel like there's been a shift through
the pa well
two things i think i gave a talk
recently and um
you know he said one of the stats that
came up when i did a lot of surveys i do
like you know happiness health checks
and companies and the surveys with the
employees and you know they were saying
that actually the top five things for
them what can i connect here do i feel
safe here do i have power here can i see
like progression
and i think do i have friends yeah and
he was just like that all sounds very
nice but if you are in latin america or
whatever like
money is definitely up there and i think
there is a question around you know
where we are in our cycle of wealth or
development and you know money is there
to build your maslows right you need
your your core things and there are
different countries around the world
where people are still striving towards
that and so now to like tap out because
of your self-actualized you don't need
the money anymore it sounds like
flippant yeah but i think we also have
to realize that we've lived for a
pandemic and for some people
businesses were lost made incomes were
changed and in some ways we were
realizing actually what else do we need
in life if your health is at stake or
you're losing family and friends or you
cannot connect with people that you care
about that becomes more vital and so
it's a question of like what do i
actually need to live off there's a
question i literally just had at lunch
and we were all like asking ourselves a
question you know a friend who like i
said shut up her business she's like
just made me realize actually i can do
pretty good
on not that much and i can really take
some space to think about what might be
next and actually it's then just
questioning what what's necessary so
accommodation
family and friends
like what is what's your level of like
going out entertainment are you what are
you willing to cut what is actually a
necessity for your life i think
everyone's going to be very different
but it is hard knowing that cut-off
point and that driving to excessness
it's like what am i sacrificing to
achieve that excess yeah
yeah i think there's a there's also an
element of
like when i speak to people about this
and when i think about it for myself
it's like this thing of like oh you know
i've i've gotta save enough money for
the future
and i've got a friend who was again in
management celtic but was thinking of
quitting her job but she was like yeah
you know if i if i stay here for another
five years they'll pay to send my kids
to private school and it's like five
years i mean yeah
but then she was laughing about it she
was like i'm not even in in a
relationship like
why am i worried about my kids five
years later
right there's so much the maps the the
map of where we're supposed to go has
been laid out or you see this so much on
instagram all these different lives and
it's like actually
like whose life am i trying to live and
in that sense you know yes she hasn't
found her partner yet but if that is
really
it's a question of what is really
important if it is really important that
her kids go to private school and get
that kind of education then in some
cases yes she does need to think about
how do i create that road map but
actually if you're just doing that
because it feels like the done thing to
do then five years that's kind of big
news around your neck to stay somewhere
yeah and i think it's similar to like oh
you know if i if i stay at this company
for x number of years then and i save 10
then i'll be able to afford a deposit on
a house and then i'll become a homeowner
and that's a big thing though right
because a lot of people do feel like not
secure enough in where they're living so
if your base is really important i think
it goes back to our question on what's
in your maslow
and if the base is really important then
yeah it might mean sticking out this
particular role of being very diligent
about what you're saving or if you're
realizing that you the work that you're
in isn't paying enough shifting
somewhere because if getting a house is
is something that helps you feel
grounded then great if it's not and you
you're happy renting then why not take
some more risk yeah i guess kind of
pulling the strings together it's it
sounds like a big part of this is
genuinely just sitting down and figuring
out like what are my priorities what are
the things i actually care about right
and then figuring out like we we don't
take the time to do that it's such an
unusual thing to do to actually sit down
for an hour and think what do i actually
care about yeah i mean it's like because
before you know it like another i mean
we're halfway over halfway through the
year right and we've already had two
years in the pandemic and you know we're
starting another year soon and it's just
time will fly yeah and you're in great
health
you have people around you so like why
don't you actually take some time some
consider time to just ask that question
and keep asking that question why do i
want to do this yeah why am i curious
about this and why do i keep telling
myself i can't do it
and just think you know where do i want
to be a year from now yeah i was
listening to this great podcast a couple
of days ago and it was just like you
know people forget that it is that
consistency that you just put in for a
couple of months six months that then
really changes the trajectory of the
next couple of years but we don't want
to be consistent yeah
it's not fun to be consistent we get
distracted and you know we are
manipulated to be distracted we are
manipulated to consume
to
like
push ourselves to distract ourselves
with music and entertainment and off
your life course and it is taking that
time to be silent and still
which is difficult yeah i found that so
like basically all of this journal is me
just sort of trying to answer the
question of what do i actually want to
do with my life and like what's
important to me and like what are value
and like why why are you not um
when you think about on one hand was
like the dream thing that you wanted to
do
and then it disappeared tomorrow how
would you feel about it like do you have
any inkling of what the idea is that you
want to do or where you want to progress
i don't know i think i think we can
you know i think also a big problem is
we can intellectualize a lot so we can
write and we can journal and do all the
other things but like you have to really
feel it in you and think about like if
this one thing i really wanted to do was
remove from the table tomorrow like how
would i feel about that i don't think
i've ever thought about the answer to
that question so i've been thinking a
lot around like what do i actually want
to do and the way i'm tackling that
question is let's say i had 100 million
in the bank and it's like at that point
surely i don't need to try but do you
need 100 million really uh no probably
not which then is the thing that i come
to later but it's it's more like let's
just pick a completely absurd number to
just put the money thing completely
aside
what is like how would i find how would
i want to spend my time
and i usually kind of land at well i'd
want to do podcasts i'd want to write my
book and i'd want to make youtube videos
occasionally about cool stuff that i
read so that's what you're doing now and
that's what i'm doing now i'm like i
don't need 100 million in the back to be
able to do that so life is good so then
is it a question of am i bored with this
oh that's a good question i'm bored of
this i don't think i am okay i think the
thing that i worry about is
does this have
a long-term future and like when i'm 65
years old will i still be like you know
what's your human design what is that do
you know so there's lots of different
profiles that you can do and your human
design profile is another one kind of
like wealth dynamics and all these
different things and it's like how are
you meant to show up in the world and so
there's different profiles there's like
the generator the manifesto the
manifesting generator the projector and
the reflector so yeah do a quick test
now
myhumandesign.com yeah
and it basically just requires your date
of birth um name and where you were born
all right and then it basically gives
you
insight into how you're actually
programmed and wired to be some people
like i'm a manifesting generator and for
a long time i am meant to do lots of
different things and i meant to show
sounds a bit pompous but like you are
meant to show the world different ways
of being okay but you i think the big
thing with manifesting generators is
that you need to make peace with the
fact that they're never going to follow
a certain line
and when people say why did you quit
that thing or why you're not doing that
thing anymore yep it's okay because
they've done what they needed to do and
they're ready to move on there are other
people who need to consistently do one
thing really well and so it might be in
your case that actually there are
multiple variations of how you're
supposed to show up but you're not
freeing yourself or allowing yourself to
let go of one thing to try something new
wait are we talking about this thing
where you insert your date of birth and
your time of birth and it just tells you
it sounds a bit woohoo but it is just so
it's really interesting to see because
it has changed the game in terms of the
way that people are allowed to
freely express themselves the same way
we've been doing profile testing for
ages right you've got myers-briggs all
of those psychometric tests i think
these ones are a little bit more
grounded
what are you
um
i am a projector interesting
what the hell does that mean so a
projector is somebody um
people are supposed to come to you for
advice yeah they do
right so you are in your right zone and
you you do require lots of rest
so there might be a level of burnout
perhaps that's causing you to rethink
where you are that's fair yeah and i
think there is a place of also not
knowing how valuable you are in the
system
in terms of the knowledge that you hold
hmm
definitely read it reading
that sounds pretty spot on
wait where does this come from
it sounds like very astrology we would
have it it is
i'm a lover of the woo and the science
okay um and it's it's basically looking
at astrology um
kind of just so many like east and
western philosophy like it's just it's a
big amalgamation of that and gene keys
is also another route
gene keys that's that's that's for a
separate podcast
yeah
gene and then keys
figuring out what your key is in terms
of again how you're supposed to show up
in the world oh wow
okay um but then you know you could also
do things like wealth dynamics which
what's wealth wealth dynamics is another
way
at looking at how
you are what's your entrepreneurial
streak okay
and so there are some people who are
really trying to be creators or
innovators and actually they are the
deal makers of the world and they're
supposed to just be connectors and to
feel or make money through connections
there are people who are supposed to be
supporters i'm one of those that are
people orientated nurturing people but
i'm not generally going to be it breaks
down different businesses when you think
of like sheryl sandberg and the way that
she operates with mark zuckerberg that's
a supportive relationship it's thinking
about
the roles that you're you're playing and
whether or not actually you're wearing
the right coat so to speak um that
sounds interesting i mean i'm gonna take
this test but i have to pay 97 for it
yes that one definitely needs sure it'll
be worth worthwhile to get some clarity
and stuff so it sounds like
you figure out this this design thing is
so interesting i'm going to stop it yeah
i mean i feel like when you go down the
rabbit hole you'll start to realize that
there are certain ways that you're being
that
you feel i shouldn't be this way but
actually that's just the way that you're
driven and the minute that you lean into
it and accept it so that's what for me
when i i accept it actually the fact
that i like to do lots of different
things it's not a bad thing and
therefore i have to give myself the
freedom and the permission that's
another thing as well when people don't
follow their dreams we don't often give
ourselves permission to try things
because we either risk the failure too
much or we just don't see the
opportunity costs yeah or we allow the
opportunity costs to defer to deter us
from making a decision but i guess if
you've done one of these things and
you're like oh yeah i really vibe with
this idea of being a projector or
whatever then in a way it sort of gives
you permission to lean into yeah and see
it's the same with wealth dynamics the
minute i stopped fighting and realizing
that actually i do fundamentally love
supporting people i was like oh actually
this comes really easy yeah yeah it's
just like the science the science part
of me is trying to figure out how the
hell does this work but i guess part of
it is even if it's not based on kind of
star alignment and stuff it's like if
you hear a description of something and
you think oh wow that actually does
really sound like me at that point in a
way
just having having that label like the
whole 16 personalities entj type stuff
is like oh yeah but i i flip between a
couple of those so i'm just like i mean
they're still inf but it's i'm an inf j
and p
i flip between the two oh yeah no even
if i put the right time zone in i'm
still a projector
the seer people who can see a better
more efficient or upgraded approach to a
specific thing and are here to share
that with others
damn strategy being invited
yeah so when you're a projector you're
not normally just offering advice
they're generally when you are when
someone says oh i'd really i'd really
like your help on x like that's when
you're in your flow when someone has
like seen your
level of expertise and calls that in
yeah yeah because i feel like i'm if i
if i'm trying to sort of shove advice
down people's throat and then asking for
it it's like it doesn't go anywhere and
yeah it's a bit pointless and someone
asked me for advice suddenly it's like
all right it's like yeah let's get
tucked in yeah yeah yeah whereas like i
think there's definitely so i know when
i'm manifesting generator i'm supposed
to be
in a space where people ask me more yes
and no questions and if i can feel into
how it feels
or i can i'm saying yes to that
wholeheartedly
that always plans out more because i've
always known in the past and i've said
yes to something that i meant no to it
hasn't worked what's your take on the
whole manifesting stuff
i i mean i i love i love both i think
that they're
all right so i i'm not just like uh
let's do affirmations i mean it's not
gonna be like okay i feel like i've i
have definitely taken some time to
really understand the neuroscience
behind it as well and how our brain
really does
evolve to shape and take on the
different
ways we think and what we continue to
think
i love listening to like subliminals and
things like that to look at how i mean
i'm massively interested in your
aesthetics which is just how our brain
and body responds to our architecture
creativity okay but also what music does
to the mind and when you mix subliminals
and affirmations or different beats to
how that changes your brain to reach to
think differently
and how that then generates new
synaptic pathways for you to think
differently about stuff so i love the
scientific approach to manifesting and
the ways that we can change i'm not just
the fluffy
print out my affirmations that works but
i think that there is a lot around how
we can really you know look at joe
dispenza's kind of stuff you know
thinking about the way that we meditate
the way that we can what we consume how
that shapes your vision
your pathway i mean the process of uh
reading the source like taurus what oh
yeah yeah yeah the science the
neuroscience behind manifestation type
stuff yeah i'm like oh wow this actually
sounds pretty legit because
previously i tried reading the secret
and i was like yes like you know
imagining your cancer is cured and your
cancer is cured clearly yes but like
that kind of stuff from a more sciency
perspective like really vibe with me and
i then started i i wrote down a bunch of
affirmations which i visit occasionally
and i do genuinely find them helpful but
i haven't yet tried the whole vision
boarding or whatever else comes with the
package of
trying to manifest your goal or your
ideal life i think it's a mixture of
things for people right you have to
think about how do i normally learn so
do i learn through visuals am i somebody
who needs to write it down
do i need to actually record some of
these manifestations and just have them
playing to me consistently i think it's
it's learning so i definitely need to
write stuff down i also need to see it
visually more consistently but i think i
have to be it is creating the space to
think am i really aligned to this thing
or is this what i think i should be
doing am i really aligned or is this
what i think i should be doing okay
because sometimes when you write down
things that you should be doing
that you're not aligned to it in the
first place and no amount of repetition
or
consistency is never gonna it's always
gonna be evading you yeah
so i guess it's sort of like yeah
because i guess you know in the in the
business context you know sometimes
there's a decision to be made but it's
like i kind of feel a bit weird about it
and i feel like i'm not fully aligned
with it but then i speak to some people
and they're like no it's probably the
right decision and i'm never quite sure
how to weigh up the sort of the gut
feeling where i feel about a decision
versus like being talked into it by
someone who seems to know what they're
talking about
but then that's that's you're not
tapping into the trust you're in a
wisdom because that i think we do a lot
of bypassing of what our intuition like
how we make decisions anyway are we more
brain the heart guts and it's thinking
about how do i consistently make
decisions
and
if i always think about things from an
intellectual perspective you're clearly
dumbing down your other kind of your
body has what's called uh pro propriety
i can never say it properly but your
body has innate wisdom and it will try
to show you
you're on the right track or you're
moving in the right way but we have
distracted ourselves so much that we
don't listen to it
so it's thinking about you know does the
hair on my neck stand up when i think
about this particular decision do i get
stomach growl butterflies
like where is the wisdom that would
actually like guide me towards making a
better decision versus just going with
what somebody else's agenda for the next
direction for me is
because they might have your best
interests at heart but equally they
might not know the full story they might
be telling you what you want to hear you
just never know so it's like how do i
develop my own
steering rod what's the science behind
the gut hot stuff are you familiar with
it because
so
we will we make uh like there is that
connected system in terms of how we make
decisions right so some people are
naturally
um it will just be from the cognitive
space and then there are other people
who are like actually if i get a heart
felt like
this is it then that's the way i'm and
they will
not listen to anything cognitive and
then there are others who are like i
just know intuitively in my gut that
this is the right way forward and they
always make decisions from the gut
so it's noticing what's my default
practice and how could i
train myself to think differently
or actually if i know that i'm always
making gut impulsive decisions and
they're not quite right then yes having
some accountability would be useful to
steer me in a different direction
because when was the last time you made
a solid decision about your business
without asking for any advice and it's
turned out correctly because that's
another thing when we don't trust
ourselves to make decisions you
generally keep defaulting it to other
people yeah that's a good point i feel
like i often feel like especially as the
business has grown and the team has
grown i feel like out of my depth in
terms of oh we've got this team of 18
people now like what the hell do i know
about managing a team therefore let me
lean on other people's advice or
reading a thing that i read in a book
and kind of really indexing hard on that
and people in the team will joke that oh
crap he's reading another business book
now we're gonna have a whole change of
direction because he's just read
something new that seems to vibe with
him
whereas i don't think
i
at all just think what do i actually
want to do in this situation and i
always kind of assume that someone else
has the knowledge i guess because from a
kind of science medical background as
well especially it's like obviously as a
junior how much time are you using how
much how much longer are you going to
use that as a stick to beat yourself
with yeah because fundamentally yes that
was your path where you started out and
there's so much transferable skills from
the science and medical field that
you're leaning into now but also you've
built this business
it's profitable
like clearly you know what you're doing
in this phase and i think we don't take
enough credit for what is working where
we have made decisions what has been
successful yeah and we keep kind of
saying actually i used to be this and
therefore that person doesn't know how
to do this situation yeah therefore i
need to read a book and get advice and
then maybe do a thing that doesn't quite
feel right but i'm like oh this person
probably knows what they're talking
about you know this is what i should be
doing at this side of the business or
whatever and clearly i'm still out of my
depth but the more you tell yourself
that the more it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy yeah you will always feel out
of your depth yeah that's just so true
yeah i'm just thinking about kind of a
bunch of business themed stuff that i've
been thinking about in the last like
week or two i just think how i often
just
really second guess like i kind of know
what the thing i want to do is but i
always think oh no that can't possibly
be right but why not
okay i guess
okay so this is interesting breakdown i
guess part of it is
okay so i tend to be quite like a fast
mover with things it's like if i have an
idea i'm like all right cool let's just
do the thing and but then traditional
business advice is that yes that works
when you're a team of one or two people
when you have a team of lead that's
bigger you then necessarily have to slow
down you have to spend time
getting people up to speed and like
building the systems and the processes
and all the stuff
and there's something about that that
feels super frustrating because it's
like uh i just want to move faster and i
would i just want us to have that kind
of scrappy startup mentality that we had
like two years ago so you're not a
startup anymore yeah exactly so that's
one area in which there's this sort of
me wanting to go in a particular
direction at a particular speed okay
but like very reasonably people point
out that actually
maybe you've got to slow down and so
that's one of those areas in which i
find there's this constant tension
between the way i want to do things and
the way i would do things by default
versus the way you're supposed to do
things once you're no longer a startup
once you're a team of like 15 20 people
and i wonder if part of that is you
needing to exercise your creativity
maybe elsewhere beyond this or in
something where you feel like you can
try and break something but not
necessarily yeah do it in the business
yeah perhaps there is an
an energy
that needs to be outsourced elsewhere
yes it's disrupting what's going on in
the business or looking at how you do
create moments for innovation in the way
that you are working but what what might
that look like with minimal disruption
like what could we hack and trial and
test before it becomes embedded as a new
way of being yeah yeah that's a good
point yeah i think one thing that like
we we've been sort of seriously thinking
about is like before we were sort of
based on kind of quarterly planning is
like you know let's do things in a
90-day segment sprints yeah yeah but
then that's always felt like super slow
so now one idea i'm just like if we
could just do six-week sprints rather
than 12-week sprints so just try it with
one thing versus like turning the the
whole engine or your car in a completely
different direction
because otherwise yeah you do force your
team to burn out
and they also then get into a place
where i don't know
like what we're trying
like next so then it's the lack of trust
in you and your leadership okay so i
guess there is that level of like listen
to your gut but like don't obviously do
it does it need to be action though i
think maybe also i don't know if you
have a ceo but like that bouncing of
ideas around okay this is what i want to
explore okay is that from my is it from
an ego place
is it for it could it genuinely benefit
the people in the business yeah
why does this need to be executed now
could it wait three months
um
and what could i try outside of this
that perhaps would be a useful way for
me to discharge that energy and i guess
like yeah how can we run the experiment
in like a small way that doesn't
necessarily disrupt the whole business
100 it just sees how things go with just
see how it goes and then you know you
get people involved and then they think
actually we've co-created this change
and we're on board with it versus it
being something that you've just forced
right this is how we're doing things
scrap that whole thing we've just been
working on for six months we're doing it
this way yeah you know one point you
mentioned burnout what do the the sort
of signs and symptoms of burnout look
like with the people that you you coach
through careertech stuff i think there's
different stages so i think we'll start
off in that place of you know we all
want to do well if you're driven you
will want to kind of like excel but then
it moves into that state where
it's the progression or the the movement
or the doing is then outweighing just
looking after your general self
and you
other people are starting to notice that
in you but you're not ready to accept it
or acknowledge it yet there's that cycle
of just general irritability with other
people maybe you are
frustrated with lack of pace
the way that people are doing things
you're starting to nitpick and depending
on how you exhibit stress some people go
into
that kind of fight mode where they're a
little bit more micromanaging over
analytical and then other people will
generally slow down so they might
actually completely become desensitized
lean back very immobile or move into
people-pleasing
and so i think when we get into that
point as well we then can suffer from
quite a lot of stomach issues
gastrointestinal kind of
problems that's when it's often been the
stress has been underlying in the body
for quite a while
and then lots more
psychological concerns around loneliness
or just you know that fear of
not being good enough and then what does
that lead to in terms of who am i and
what's my place and
do people will people
miss me like it can spiral so i think we
can go through lots of different stages
it's just noticing how do i catch myself
when i've been pushing too hard or doing
too much
and actually not listening to those that
can notice these signs before i have
perhaps yeah and so if we find ourselves
like catching those kind of early
warning signs what are the things that
we can do to kind of reverse things or
remedy things so i think it's definitely
noticing like how are you triggered
around stress like what is causing you
to
feel out of sorts or to be irritable you
know some people also have more physical
symptoms so you might be noticing
actually if i've constantly got colds
and i'm run down or my joints are aching
or you know like
how do we take a moment and pause and
think actually what might have been
going on in the way that i'm eating
or the way that i could slow what can i
slow down what can i start to delegate
let go of some people it might be
through memory loss so what am i filling
my brain with so a lot of people suffer
from cognitive symptoms that are a bit
more about you know forgetfulness or
feeling massively overwhelmed all the
time and you know what could you do to
create some more white space in your
calendar
so moving i think sometimes we try to
move from like deep attention tasks you
know the stuff that could we can get
through in 90 minutes and like blitz on
that and then we have more of the kind
of open attention stuff which is emails
and stuff like that but where's the
white space in between that the time to
just do nothing maybe just to go into
nature just to
pause for a second to eat to just be i
don't think there's enough of that in
the calendar for many people
i think there's also something about the
arts you know just spent a year doing a
therapeutic arts and educational program
and it's looking at how through the art
making process our brain changes and
kind of helps us to problem-solve
differently to disassociate from stress
and that could also just be through
fitness it could be through going to see
something
creative but that has the power to help
us to relax and to loosen tension and
stress i think there's also you know
just keeping a general diary of how
things have been going and maybe just
retrospectively just thinking actually
how did i tackle last week and why have
i found myself in a position
where i'm burnt out oh am i
you know doing too much was i people
pleasing and taking on too many things
how can i kind of reframe how i might
show up this week differently yeah i
feel like kind of when i feel those
warning signs in myself of like
sort of that feeling of like ugh i kind
of can't be bothered to do this
it's often because
there's like no white space in the
calendar it's like going from one thing
to another thing to another thing one
thing over once it's like oh [ __ ] and
i'm running late for the other one
there's like anxiety that builds up that
i'm just never on time i'm never doing
enough i'm not there for people
you know all of that narrative then
starts to accumulate that often leads me
to think oh you know is this really the
right thing like do i really want to be
doing this business do everyone want to
be anything usually right
that's why i asked you if you were just
bored because sometimes when we get to
this place of
boredom or there's some sort of tension
or perhaps we are burnt out everything
just looks like it's catastrophic
you know it's that like
you know oh god i just wish this thing
would burn to the ground i'm over it and
you know especially women when we go
through
cycles there will be those periods in
the month where it's just like actually
this is too much i'm not interested next
week you're like oh my god it's the best
thing in the world so it's like you know
honoring the cycle and our hormones and
the way that we're built so
just you know questioning am i
done with the way that i'm working or am
i actually just tired
and a break would help me have some
perspective and to step back and think
okay what might i do differently as i
re-enter i was having a call with one of
our team members earlier today and we
were talking about like youtube channel
and various issues with that stuff and i
was like what do you think i should do
and he was like honestly i think you
need to take a break for a month and
just spend some time alone in nature and
like just like think
and i was like that's a pretty good shot
but would you do that though uh probably
not
because i'd be like oh but there's all
this other stuff that i have to do and
like but that does it's a vicious cycle
because if you don't take that you're
then just going to produce content for
the sake of producing content which your
heart and soul won't really be in yeah
so it's like the break maybe it's not a
month maybe the month in itself feels
like whoa that's too much could i start
with a couple of days or a week of just
like not thinking about it and maybe i
go back to just doing one or two
episodes a week versus trying to bash
out 20 or whatever yeah that's a good
point i i do have like one of these sort
of retreat type things booked for like
in august sometimes okay i like to put
your phone away for three days live in a
cabin in the woods kind of vibes but
even then i was like i really want to do
this thing i was like there's no space
in the calendar until like four months
down the line
and i was thinking i was kind of
thinking hmm it feels like there's
something off if that that's what's
going on but i guess i just need to sort
of explore it with with me and the team
to figure out like
there's got to be some time for like
recharging yeah there has to be you know
jerry collins talks about this he's
website is reboot.io and he talks a lot
about
he does podcasts with different ceos and
founders and you know he talks about his
annual retreat
and that time in solace to just really
reset recharge because otherwise he's no
good to the people he's working with
yeah i should really make time to do one
of these things that would be that would
be quite handy i'd love to talk a little
bit about the idea so we sort of vaguely
touched on this briefly but this idea of
kind of following your passions
so when it comes to careers i feel like
this would have been a bit of a sine
wave in terms of like people's sort of
sentiment about this where i feel like
back in the day was very much like pick
the thing you're passionate about and
follow the passion and then
through
the rise of like cal newport's book so
good they can't ignore you which is all
about basically oh the passion thing is
myth like my passion is to play football
but i'm not gonna make living playing
football realistically therefore
find something
and just become really good at it and
then you'll naturally become passionate
about the things that you're good at but
then there's then there's still some
people that are like oh but like you've
got to fundamentally have some level of
passion about it what's what's your take
on the whole like
finding out the thing you're passionate
about and making that the thing that you
do for work i feel like purpose has to
go through a process of creating and
distilling and experimenting
i think it's not about
you know there's lots of things that i'm
passionate about you know i love cooking
i love you know doing all these things
but can i see myself doing that
day-to-day you know yeah no so i think
there's a there's a question like do i
want to be a chef no but i think there's
a question of
there's lots of things that we are
tempted to try or that we're curious
about but we don't actually again give
ourselves permission to experiment to
treat it like a scientific experiment
could i pick three things that i'm
curious about to see exactly what
spectrum of passion i sit on with this
thing so it might be that you're a
photographer
or
you're curious about architecture or
maybe you're curious about making in
shoes or or making clothes and so it's
about okay could i give myself a day
sprint to really think about
interviewing somebody who is an
architect speaking to somebody who
curates an exhibition or is a is a
photographer that teaches under 14s how
to use you know vintage cameras i think
if we don't really break down all of
those different avenues or spend some
time understanding it we can't then make
a critical decision about
what it is that you say you're
passionate about
we can we all have these things that
we'd love to do but fundamentally when
you get into the nitty-gritty it might
be that actually i love photography but
i don't really want to take photos of
people i probably want to look at the
technical side of you know what is a
great photo maybe i love teaching and so
perhaps i want to teach about
photography but i don't need to be you
know running my own shows or having an
exhibition somewhere yeah but you won't
know that until you try
and so i think
part of the purpose
journey is experimenting and distilling
and actually just do you know what i
thought i really love this thing but i
bloody hate the people that it attracts
or it's going to be a lot of money and
maybe that's not where i want to spend
my funds or fundamentally i'm actually
no good at this thing so i need to let
go of it yeah but i think we don't get
there i think we want to do this fully
evolutionary like tomorrow i am going to
be a podcaster and you start to do it
and then you realize actually i don't
want to interview people like i kind of
want to do solo things like
yeah but you don't know until you try
yeah and i think every time i i invite
my clients to think okay let's
experiment with this let's play
and see at different opposite ends of
the spectrum you know one lady she's
like oh my god okay so i found some
people on linkedin
i've got
coffees with them to interview them and
then i had a chat with one person and
she's like actually 80 of the job is
this and she's like i just don't want to
do that
and i really thought that the way this
job was sold
actually if i'm spending 80 percent of
my time doing that i don't think i
wanted it
yeah so i don't want to move in that
direction so
i think there's there's that process of
trial and error peeling away like how do
i show up doing this thing yeah and do i
need to be under the weight of this
thing has to carry me for the next five
10 20 years until i'm 60. no it could
actually be that you're a serial
specialist and you spend five years
doing that thing
and then you put it to bed and it's five
years doing something else
i think we have to let go of these rules
and this kind of like prescription
around what it needs to look like and
again it comes back to the fundamentals
what do i need to live off what are the
basic things that i really need to care
about and then how do i springboard off
there um i'd love to talk more about
this this sort of purpose question um
in the sense of like
i feel like there is a balance between
actively looking for the purpose in the
thing that you happen to be doing
versus like
looking internally to find out what sort
of purpose you want to have in the world
and then finding a thing that does that
if that makes sense
so you're saying that it's the either
active searching for something and then
hoping that it then is part of your
mission or who you're supposed to be
versus
thinking about how you want to affect
change on the planet and then doing that
is that what you mean yeah no i guess
like let's say if you've got a job right
now then in one like you know there's
all this stuff around how finding
purpose and the thing that you uh so
sort of feeling like you're having
that your work is aligned with your
purpose or something like that
contributes to this feeling of things
being energizing and more sustainable
and more enjoyable but to what extent is
that a case of hey this is this is the
this is the job i've got let me try my
best to figure out where the positions
love it or leave it right i think it's
that thing of is this
is this job that i'm doing
is there some element or grain that i
can find purposeful or that is that
where you're going yeah yeah yeah right
versus the thing of like i need to i
need to even create purpose for myself
i mean i think this is this is the basis
of what i want to get i get people to
think about in the book is like what
kernels or seeds of joy purpose
alignment are you finding in this
existing role
because you know a lot of the time we
want to jump from the frying pan into
another fire
thinking that purpose is over there a
purpose looks like this
and without any prior knowledge or
insight or whatever but and realizing
actually there's a good thing that we
have here and maybe it does create the
spaciousness for other things to come up
into my life that feel purposeful i
think it's a fine line isn't it between
the constant chasing for purpose
versus
sitting with and knowing like you know
ramit's safety equals this um he talks
about the different phases of your
career you know are we am i in that
growing phase do i want more of the
lifestyle phase or actually am i kind of
what's the last one
i think he talks about growing is where
you're going to be head down to the
grind and you want to kind of keep
building the skills and actually purpose
doesn't matter then
and in the lifestyle part of your life
or whether or not you're moving into
that it is about actually i want to be
able to pick up my kids and i want to be
able to volunteer
and you know and then the other one is
maybe i just want to make a complete
career pivot that feels more aligned to
something i'm socially
engaged with
so it's noticing maybe where you are in
your journey too i think that's also a
really powerful point yeah yeah i think
for me the the question of purpose
it almost feels like once i've
i i feel like okay cool i've got this
like this is good you know for the point
of the business is to kind of help
people live their best lives and the way
we do that is through youtube videos and
podcasts and book and all that kind of
stuff that feels great and then like a
few weeks will go by and i'll have that
sort of those signs of burnout of like
oh i'm not sure and then i'll second
guess the purpose and think is that
really i mean am i i guess am i feeling
a bit like uh about it because i
fundamentally don't vibe with the
purpose or is it just because i'm tired
right now and just haven't eaten for a
while i just need to take a little bit
of a break but then you know if i then
push you on it you're not taking the
break that you need to so you're always
going to be in this vicious cycle
constantly questioning yourself whereas
actually if you did give yourself some
break some time you know some ideas
might bubble up that actually this is
the right direction or it might be
actually no we do need to pivot but
you're not stopping yes to think
yeah because i guess it's too easy to
kind of go down a bit like oh yeah and
just keep going yeah
and i i don't know i wonder if there's
also this
thought around yes you want to create
content that really does reach and
change but it's okay to pivot and say
actually our content needs to maybe do a
slight move in this direction and that's
okay too because maybe that's also the
the heming in of purpose needs to look
like we're talking about this and we
only talk about these things on this
channel and maybe that's also where
you're feeling a bit blocked creatively
perhaps yeah i think that's very true
okay so like let's say you were like
coaching me and we were having a
one-on-one session or something like
that hypothetically
and i would like to be like samantha
yeah i'm kind of feeling the sense of
burnout i'm kind of feeling this sense
of like not really sure what direction
the business is supposed to be going in
we kind of have a good thing going we
like we're pretty profitable have decent
margins we have a great team like the
vibes are strong so i like i really
enjoy coming into the studio each day
and the people that i work with
but there's something about like the
content or the mission or something
that's feeling like
a bit like not
not quite aligned is it the content or
the mission or is this you just not
feeling like enough is enough what do
you mean not feeling like
you know sometimes we can be incessantly
changing evolving pushing yeah because
maybe you know we all have different
scripts again that we can live by and
some of them is perfectionism like
to be successful i need to be perfect
and all the ducks need to be aligned or
we were accepted or loved when we were
younger when we were doing more more
more more
when we were creating or perhaps in
order for us to be
recognized we had to be constantly
achieving
and so you know i try and get my clients
to think about where is the need for the
pivots where is it coming from and is
the mission the statement thing a
distraction from
actually like you said this is really
good right now and am i just pushing a
match to burn it down
because it needs to be or am i or is
this my my habit that i need to keep
going for more and more and more or
actually is it time for me to change and
actually i'm feeling stagnant so mission
feels like one part of the problem but
there's something else yeah i think
there's a combination of all three
things i was having this conversation
with a friend over dinner yesterday
around like when it comes to a business
like when is enough enough it's like
when have we gotten to the point where
we've got enough growth or enough
revenue or enough profitability for it
to be like
there's it's all good
but then the other side of the coin is
you know people say well you know if
you're not growing then you're declining
and
you could be growing in other ways you
know maybe there is a part of you that
is craving another life stage and if the
business is ticking off nicely yeah what
else could be available to you yeah and
if you were to take the business to that
next level what will it then take from
you or take for you to do that and are
you okay with that too
because with growth comes other
sacrifices yeah you know we when we
definitely found that kind of going from
a team of like zero to two to four to
ten to eighteen whereas just like at
every stage of growth it's it's felt
like we're solving a bunch of problems
by hiring a bunch of people but then
we're creating a bunch more
problems right yeah and in a way it's
like and then whose vision is it like
you know what's the vision that you had
initially when you started the business
was it you know sprawling mass of lots
of teams in different locations and
filming videos
or you know was it something where
there's me and maybe a team of four and
we're just pushing out amazing content
and that's okay
but actually the world that i'm in
requires me to scale and grow and
actually that's not what i want to do
yeah i feel like my views on this often
change depending on the person i'm
speaking you're speaking right and so
again who are you pleasing yeah because
i did an interview with a chap called um
will mccaskill a few a few months ago
it's like one of the few weeks actually
one of the founders of the effective
altruism movement and he is you know
this like you know typical guy written a
bunch of books and
sort of caps his salary at 27k a year as
he like started off at 20 and then just
adjusted for inflation and he just
donates all of the other hundreds of
thousands he makes to charity every
every year and he was just like yeah i
mean it's great like i don't need to
worry about money i think like i've got
my basics covered like life is good i'm
just focused on the mission but then i
would listen to a podcast or interview
someone who's one of these like 10
million 100 million entrepreneurs right
suddenly it's like oh you know here's
how we chase that next level of growth
and stuff
and then i start thinking oh that sounds
pretty good
but does it though do you like the
person that you would need to become to
get there because it's not a bad thing
it's not a right or wrong thing but it's
just questioning do i want to be that
person because it will take
a different version of you
a different level of pace yeah to do
that consistently yeah do you want to do
that yeah i don't think so i think i
prefer a chill lifestyle so then honor
that and own it right because with that
means that actually
the need for us to keep growing and
scaling is not going to take me towards
that lifestyle life
but then i need to make pace with that
and then i also need to be able to talk
about that with confidence and
conviction to others yeah and if i can't
do it then i'm still not sold on that
vision so i guess that comes down to
basically taking some time to think
about it always circles back to us
you and you alone yeah
you know all these other voices are
powerful you know it's great to have
an army or a family or grow up with that
community that is there to ask you these
questions to push you to not be
complacent
but then fundamentally as well if we get
pushed from pillar to post by different
voices different thoughts
you'll never have
the concrete direction of what you want
and the business that you want to build
you'll be building everyone else's
version of what your business should be
and there's nothing wrong with it i
think there's also this there was a
great article the other day i can't
remember where it's from but i was
forwarded about the myths of the
lifestyle business
and it was talking about how you know a
lot of these people that we aspire to
become all had initial lifestyle
businesses to begin with
and it's like why do we make
that a
uh the stigma that we need to chase
investment we need to grow we need to be
bigger and better and fundamentally
the world's changed and it's like
actually how is
is that really relevant for you
do you want what comes along with that
some people are like yes hell yes then
go for it but if actually there's a part
of you that's like yeah so part of me is
like
right then you know it's not it's not
for you you just have to be able to be
at peace with that decision yeah and i
guess it comes back to partly that thing
of like when is enough enough yeah it's
like what is the level of growth
profitability revenue that i'd be like
actually this is pretty solid and now we
don't need to grow anymore we just need
to yeah and then it's growth in
different ways
yeah
growth in different ways yeah what does
that mean for you know if your team are
at a place where you know you're
delivering and everything's working like
how are they growing in different ways
how might you grow in different ways how
might it create the space for you to try
new things
yeah i feel like once we got to the
point where kind of the business was
sufficiently like was was working well
enough then suddenly i became much more
interested in like like oh
team member x you've been thinking of
starting a youtube channel for a while
let's figure out how to make that happen
or things like that you wouldn't have
time to do that if you're scaling to
like get to 10 mil plus plus you might
but i mean it would then take a lot more
from you yeah so what's more important
yeah i like that framing kind of growing
in different ways because it like it
taps into that part of me that's like i
want to grow but it's like
growing does not have to be growing
revenue and growing headcount it can be
growing it's growing in different ways
you know and i think it's being open to
like where do i feel like i'm not
growing and perhaps that is also a
frustration that's causing you to kind
of want to break parts of business or
want to grow but actually there's growth
that you want to do personally yeah
changing gears slightly how do you think
about the balance when it comes to
working with people in terms of giving
appropriate feedback versus not wanting
to be mean and like wanting to keep
people happy and keep their
everything everything's all good
everything's all
fine and dandy versus like oh actually
we have a problem here and this needs to
be some level of like negative feedback
given to some more constructive
criticism or things like that yeah i
think we have to yeah i think it's
important to be able to solicit feedback
and to be able to give it to i think if
there's no point
playing nice or people pleasing or
fitting everything into a nice little
box i think it's definitely the way that
you deliver it but when you stop having
courageous conversations with people
your team starts to wonder what you're
not telling them lots of silence build
up yes and before you know it you've got
you know people that don't trust you
or aren't really aligned anymore because
they just know that there's something
else that's up and i think
this
state that we're in in terms of work you
know there's been a lot of breakdown
because of lack of trust in management
or a lack of an ability to be
transparent about what's needed here to
grow or how i can be you know there's
the spectrums like there's radical
candor or you know we can still deliver
it in a tone that is gets your point
across without being mean
i think you have to if you cannot
confidently give constructive
criticism then you're no good to your
friends your team anyone that's the only
way that we grow when you think about
the psychology model of how we're set up
right so joseph fluff and harry ingram
created this model
and for each of us we have four
different areas so there is like who we
are as self
and that's what you show the world
that's what you tell people and that's
how people like see you
and then there is this element that is
our blind spots
and that is the area that you need to
solicit some feedback or get curious
about and people can say actually you
know what ali you really do this
frustrating thing when you kind of go
off in two different tangents and we
don't really know what you're thinking
and it then
doesn't enable us to make
plans
that's important knowledge for you to
know and it's a blind spot
we also have an area that is a mask
right which is what we use as a
protective shield to not show people
about us and that's through more
self-disclosure and discovery that
people can learn about who you are i
think the last quadrant is just unknown
by everybody so it's through more and
more of this feedback sharing
this
curiosity
that we need to have for each other that
we can start to learn how to be better
humans
but if you're not willing to or you get
shy at giving um taking feedback you're
not necessarily going to be able to give
it either yeah i feel like this is one
long coaching session for you it's so
good i'm just like my mind is just being
bloated all like all across all fronts i
think i think you talked about this a
bit in the book it's like people wanting
kind of varied roles with sort of the
idea of people wearing multiple hats
within
within a team versus the idea of like
having a very clearly defined like your
job is x and you're doing this one thing
when we were in startup land we were
very much multiple hats multiple things
and then we sort of i think probably
over-indexed a bit too much on like
business structure and org charts and
all that jazz where it's like kind of
really wants to put someone in a box
with a very defined set of
responsibilities which mean that a bunch
of people we've got on the team feel
like i kind of joined the team kind of
hoping that i get involved in everything
but now i've been siloed into this
division that's just one this one thing
because apparently that's what the orc
chart says any any thoughts on that
balancing act i mean i think it's
through more of those conversations with
people to realize like what they're
really good at and i think there has to
be some specificity
as the business grows in terms of
actually yes you're in charge of that
and you can own that and be autonomous
in how you deliver in your role but
i think that's the phase of going from
start up to scale up right people need
you need to get some sort of structure
for this thing to work otherwise people
are just burning out all over the place
yeah i think that that was the problem
we had in startup mode where it's like
everyone was doing everything but like
working 100 hour weeks right and then
suddenly things have to have because you
can't sustain that so you know i think
it's it's par for the course is that you
do need some
um some structure in there but i think
it's more a case of are we giving people
the autonomy to deliver
and work in a way that's effective for
them yeah i guess with this like again
like i i i wonder about the autonomy
thing because it's like to
like
i guess
different people want different levels
of autonomy in the sense that there are
some people that we have who are like
yeah just tell me the direction we're
going and i'll just do i'll just like
make it happen and then and then there
are others that are like no i would
really appreciate
a clearer sense of direction and like
what specifically you want me to do
and regular check-ins to yeah that's the
nature of humanness right
i think that's the nature of just how we
show up and i guess it's just how do you
cultivate a culture that responds to
that and allows those who need the free
will and the free reign and others who
need a bit more direction and what do
you want more of in the team do you want
more of self-motivated go off and do
what on your own and that requires you
to trust them and to relinquish control
or is there a part of you that still
wants to be able to
micromanage or to look after or to own
to a certain degree yeah it's like my
initial gut is like oh i love it if
people accept directed and stuff but
then i'm thinking oh but like obviously
i'd want to quality control everything
right so then there's a part of you
involved in all the processes and be
like yeah then i might as well just do
it myself yeah like you have to i think
and this is how your management style
will shape and affect whether or not
those people feel like they are
you know working in a way that's
effective for them or they just kind of
feel like actually
can't make a move without
you breathing down my neck about how i
do things yeah okay thank you this has
been incredibly helpful
i'd love to turn the conversation back
to the book for a moment um so like who
who is the book aimed at who who's the
sort of people that you're would benefit
from checking it out i really feel like
it's it's weird when i look at my
workshops it was predominantly i would
say people who were maybe
in their mid-30s upwards who were like
i've been doing this job for a while
and there was probably a lot of
psychological bang it baggage and
um
conflict around changing and so
by then they have the sort of trappings
the house the kids
the
maybe they're looking after aging
parents and then it's the risk it feels
too much to then move
what i've realized later is that there
is a lot more of a younger audience as
well who are like actually
i love the freedom of creating a
portfolio career or the fact that i
never really thought about how i show up
in certain situations and now i can
understand how i communicate differently
with people or why i keep having the
same tired argument it's for people who
are on the cusp of making a change in
their career or
are questioning you know is this path
for me and how can i disrupt it and what
might i do differently and actually want
to be taken through a series of
exercises it's practical in that sense
so i really wasn't aiming it for someone
who's just going to read it put it down
and be like oh that was a nice book i
really want it to be almost like a
bible that you go back to like a manual
that you can pick up and maybe you don't
read it straight away but maybe you read
love it and then actually you're at a
leave it stage and that bit becomes more
relevant or actually there's a certain
chapter that's really helped you think
about change differently i'd say it's
for everyone no but i mean fundamentally
because everyone who started some kind
of career yeah
in a career transition you know really
trying to make the most out of their
existing career because i think what's
what's interesting is that i get a lot
of people say to me you know i had no in
no intention of leaving i think i just
want to make what i'm doing better yeah
or you know it did make me question
whether or not leaving was the right
decision in the first place and it
started somewhere new and the same
problems are there so it's i'm realizing
i'm the problem not the company
nice and we'll put links to the book in
the video description in the show notes
wherever a year wherever people happen
to be listening or watching this yeah i
just want to say thank you so much for
coming on and for the little private
personal coaching session so i really
appreciate that
you've given me a lot to think about i'm
gonna have a good long look at my
calendar and be like right what is going
on here that's that's causing what feels
like it's causing a bunch of these
things
and
yeah just the idea of instead of me
thinking that someone else has the
answers and therefore i can just rely on
their personal opinion it's like
taking their opinion but taking with a
grain of salt and like connecting it
with what i feel is the right decision
to make because i feel like you've made
i think that's the thing it's like
becoming more trusting of the decisions
that you're making yeah so realize that
you know you were a doctor before and
you realize that that was not the right
career for you so you made a decision to
leave that proved to be successful yeah
like let's not under let's not like
downplay that you've now started a
business which is successful so you can
make decisions yeah you have proved
before that you have made a series of
good decisions
so therefore when it comes to your next
step don't default that to other people
look back at your capacity to think
about
and tune into what you want and give
yourself the the space
to play with that but it does require
some downtime you know i think
we don't allow rest to play a huge role
in us creating and developing we think
it's like more more more now now now and
actually it's the rest where you get
your best creative ideas and also that
you know as i move into more of the kind
of new aesthetics and thinking about
this art science bridge you know the
realization that in the down times in
the play in the
idleness is where you find parts of
yourself and where your brain is
working through problems in that
subconscious space to give you new
answers that if you didn't create the
space you would never hear i'll check
out more of that human human design
stuff because that's super intriguing i
was like whoa [ __ ] that sounds like
super spot on and all i did was give it
my date of birth
this is it
people you know we have to uh be open to
other ways of seeing ourselves yeah
rather than purely the cognitive yeah
yeah well thank you so much my pleasure
thank you all right so that's it for
this week's episode of deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are gonna be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the itunes store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full hd or
4k on youtube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye